all right right right are amazing
happiness expertise please join me in
welcoming Roberto aguirre-sacasa
deafness future of the Vale our favorite
head sizes welcome family
[Applause]
this joke
and Sheryl blossom
here's a summary as Joseph boy now round
after all kill as many Valentines
[Applause]
you guys fresh off of a plane in color
these lovely bear said there are
veterans are over rail
well also amazing have here I need to
know where are other chocolate people in
Riverdale anytime so maybe I don't love
this us at gas grill to plan this event
seasons bloopers I have ever seen
you guys look like you're having so much
fun on set together it tastes things off
with a little quick onset pop quiz and
the chantry's I would call out the
co-stars a little bit who's on the cab
places those pranks on set cold roast
and a television monitor great stuff we
also have we have new Reggie for season
2 and she has immediately solidified
some who breaks into giggles until the
scene of those changes let me give up
drill who can always pick now snacking
on Julie crappy because me maybe has a
lot of workers guts they consume so much
food is almost disgusting
whose clothes guilty I was constantly
taking selfies in between takes and I
loved every nothing with this cat I
don't know they hit a most on set Chloe
actually we think he'll up in the green
room who's wearing always like early
first answer the call of the Josephine
we have so much business for season to
talk about right now but of course we
have to dress the big finale cliffhanger
Fred Andrews we shop we do not know what
is going to happen but I do know that
Roberta there I can chime in and give us
a little tease and what we're going to
be in the season choose where yeah I
think we're going to find out ultimate
fate at the end of the premiere you a
little affair with Archie bringing Fred
the hospital the first episode is
basically Archie's again all of the town
sort of sitting waiting on him what's
going to happen with the president it
will be revealed at the end of the first
episode we're all going for him though
well KJ how is friend getting shot and
that arches world knew typically such an
optimistic guy announced BFF Anjali
useful and dad got shot and we here at
the dark Archie she pretty much
crucially dealing with free beam shot
and at first episode there's a lot of
things going on and it's like at he's
almost
they got us off and I think 100 scenes
it's a completely different side dodge
that we haven't really seen in so you
know when I read that they'd give its
own I would heady kyonyuu
it would be how are you going to juggle
football music and your dad and he I'm
in quite a pickle for you there I'm
really excited to announce said we're
getting 22 glorious episode Sara how
does having 9 additional episodes shape
the writers room have more we really
played this year I think we funny we
thought that we'd have a ton of room to
sort of do one-off episode sort of like
Ferris Bueller's Day Off but there's so
many great characters and there's so
many stories intelligence we've seen I
think it's more of that pedal to the
metal
aggressive storytelling and juggling
Aldous characters you look so fun to see
different characters winner on that side
of things or agendas here with more time
Roberto is there anything that you
didn't get a say in this even one that
you're like yes these inches we're doing
it yeah yeah I think the biggest thing
is like I said we have a huge cab and
we're going to get to see more we're
going to see more color this year we're
going to be more of Josie we're just
morning
and it could be we're going to be able
to do as much time stuff as we want and
then happen
for the characters and the relationships
and Oh romantic so it's really a bigger
canvas for that that's the bad thing
how you doing - follow the Godhead going
to a brand new school this year and when
we last long in the season one finale to
put on the outside service jacket what
did mindset is going to be scheming to
chuck it first into his plate kind of in
the middle of two worlds that are
starting to collide really abroad and as
an Air Act sort of as incident is
progressive and it's going to start
forcing him to really kick a side which
is quite a dangerous place for him to be
and he's a very morally gray character
and I think a few tree precautions for
his narrative and then and with his
relationships with the rest of the cast
and bullshitty how this relationship was
Betty going in also I mean it also gets
tested is his character is now very much
the outsider I mean he started at the
kind of intellectually boring characters
the beginning of season one and now now
he is physically away from the entire
path which is a strange place trying to
be him well we saw Alvin who is over at
the new high school we surprised was
fitting in really well
infinity embrace on the surface and
embracing between students it's kinda
like a noose on family I don't think
it's going to be as easy as he assumes I
I already in from welcome to shoot
without spoiling too much cheese
I think he has an idea of fitting in and
he's quite a special smells everything
these five special smells like and he'll
stand out and the problem with with a
dangerous system like Southside is that
standing out can be physically
threatened so we'll start seeing a
little bit of bad narrative for our core
special smells like that and this is the
question and then Roberto's thereafter
Shimon onto any word I'm judging mom and
jellybeans makes an appearance we would
we talked about it I think it might be
something that happens in the second
half of the season
yeah we just we houses on the right
happening for both of that mean it
happens everything on the ship water
right but nobody cares about both
handwriting we saw penny having a lot of
inner demons in season one as she goes
into season two or you personally
excited to kind of explore that a little
bit more and I've been in for mindset
yeah definitely from an acting
perspective is a challenge so it's good
to take that on and I think as the
scripts have been coming in and as we
started filming a lot I don't know like
last season we saw some direct weddings
with this season it's more like tortures
goal that and it's really really
I didn't display it but also kind of
it's a little heart-wrenching for my
character and little Betty by them but
yeah I mean there's that we explore that
darkness a lot more and I think we see
that you can come to terms with that
little bit more entities rather than try
and just cover it with a black wig and
she's been determined this darkness and
trying to figure it out or be anything
early more Jughead ranca or Archie as
she goes through this you know what I
think just kind of like I don't know
when I can express some tomato don't say
everyday I think it's quite even I think
she's finds a different comfort in every
single one of them and but I do think
you definitely see more of many in
Archie's friendship and their support
system and and that they are they have
the best friends or Hawaiians are not
something that you really get to see in
season 2 which you know makes me happy
because it just kind of skins a little
bit more background these two people who
grew up next to each other and then as
much as I love many signature iconic
ponytail already her hair down a little
bit you really is the third rail right
now really yeah
any loosen her ponytail a little bit a
little e I was like if I thought if you
have to learn ponytail I really like a
[Music]
[Applause]
hairy growing real tired home we had
Mark Consuelos
coming on eat into the plate first of
all I know local like welcoming him into
the wash family it was effortless on a
busy London and as soon as he got here
and it is he plays the role of such
confidence and selfie like he's not like
trying to push this Godfather character
which he just so calm collected so at
the end of the day their business man
and he knows how they put on a face and
like charm people but the whole time I
mean I'm so delicious I don't how did
you describe their father-daughter bond
it's layered I think there's a side of
ronica that really wants to know that
he's better now or that he's going to
try to be a good person but at the same
time he's still doing the same things
he's always doing and to be secret with
her money and their kind of like not
letting veronika cross that bridge and
she's just trying to get to them and be
like let me be part of this family I
want to be a lot like I want to help you
know she wants a secret
KJ has different shared enemies with
your go home father
come on yeah dr. human with Marcus's oh
yeah ha ha we don't afraid to stuff to
get into the grill funny thing are
really cool religious and really how
would you how they describe it Oh
Caroline Carey yeah I mean obviously
dating his daughter on the but skeptical
with that uh ninaholidays and kind of
plan yeah I'm excited too excited to
reveal something very special here
there's another fans in the back and who
Veronica's life how would you like this
okay okay I got an ex from New York
coming and be brief brings out
Veronica's dark side which only hasn't
really well
camera has our we are crying does much
larger the dirtbag there's no going back
did you have our scale about that night
I really not even throw idea tonight to
be yelling that it also we've got even
more fresh Davis coming to Riverdale in
here with announced that super girls are
brick Morgan and can be turning it as
penny keep us and forth as many we've
got brand new Reggie join the group
why would Charles Nelson is first than
perfect choice to seven a red shoes you
know we when we when we were first
attacks and registers even want it took
us forever to find the guy who kind of
embody that that was lost Butler and
then when Ross had to leave we had made
a really tough position
do we retire the character or do we try
to do to try to replace this great actor
and for me and I think for the producers
and for the cat breaking such an
important part of that shows such a big
a lamenting artsy kind of dated a rival
that I said listen if we can find the
right actor we'll do it at the camp will
retire Reggie and Charles one of the
first actors who came in and he hadn't
done because since we have everyone else
tab we made him read with KJ we made him
read with Cole we made him read with
Ashley for various reasons we have
stores with all the remember and the
chemistry were kind of in contain Ian
and as soon as I'm in got the godswood
push-ups before we went in to go fishing
I usually go to be perfect reality
completely embodies in that way your
complacency for instance not normally
does we do it together with
and also clean whenever there's another
new character coming to Riverdale Tony
topes joining the group will notice on
the [ __ ] comics Sarah was a to about
Tony Bowie playing her well look at this
thing is the actress playing or some
other we met the first year for one of
the parts but someone else was playing
and we just loved the actress so much so
when the opportunity came up bring her
she felt like she belongs in Riverdale
were very excited and she played by
Venetta Morgan my friend how do I get
cried her character where does she fit
into this world she said she talked odd
if a student at Belmont High she is
she's about my servant
she sort of Jughead guide into the
circuit world and and there's a lot
about her that that makes it seem like
honestly we don't think that she's got a
lot of the same interest as judges it's
almost like she's like a female Jughead
so so she's troubled she's trouble
probably worth playing Roberto I could
see trouble getting judgment into this
gang and I think she might be trouble
for bucket I don't know I don't know I
can hear the food that is my Holly
now something about me Gomez said in the
comments
it was suited that she could be bisexual
there is something that we're all going
to be exploring on the on screen version
no I mean she's she's sort of that's
something that goes in the comic books
and it's been for a while and we really
really want you to buy central character
from the comics on the show or a lot of
the people on this panel which leads us
to our bromance checkup I understand
we're going to confuse love interest in
to do love hey you know I think walking
out of that yeah I think the first few
episodes are really fun for Kevin to
kind of deal with that heartbreak is
very wonderfully written way by the
writers and the producers so can be
refunded to show you think there's going
to be a new bump it comes into play
enter which Roberto about that he has
the heels apart first
yeah you know again so what you guys now
what do you think Kevin looks is going
to guide children
you know I think he I think Kemper the
big lesson which walking not that you
tossed over that was again but someone
that is interesting on that thicken
himself a different job in the same way
that Kevin is in many ways pretty much
that I was editor
Ashley the last time you and I talked we
have campaigning that we needed a love
interest for Josie I might I might just
be like a bet my own massive and
resonate men anything else panel get any
new love or what role that on there
right now solution and Hari
well Cheryl Gotham really had the
phenomenally with Margie bad on fighting
for fly from stratum of for Cheryl I
mean nobody's family went Rose worse
even mom
I mean a lot of healing scenarios are
you work for that man is crying in the
audience right now is like the perfect
soundtrack we're going opening these are
you area I think when you're falling to
lead wearing monster is you know hardest
by the program of interest groups let's
check in with say and Jughead in the
finale would you guys want to see from
them some people - well I think we would
jump and going to Southside that'd be a
disturbance territory it's very scary
for Betty she doesn't want to lose her
man and also doesn't want him to get
into any danger and I think it becomes a
little bit of our Romeo and Juliet
situation that she hopes has a happy
ending they go to do my riders I'm
jogging right awesome hog just climb in
the where idea pink leather jacket you
know I took the relationship it doesn't
get me tested especially for the first
real real narrative of the second season
but it's one
things we're now more than ever season 1
the way that we kind of talk about
people one was very much the origin
story for a lot of these characters and
now the way the church's life is sort of
progressing is really stressful at this
it's our and the truth is that Joe has
one of those characters that really gets
tested the most by by the world around
him and that puts any really in a
position of possible judgment where she
and her morality has to make the choice
to either be there for this kid or you
know call it quits or for the betterment
on herself
you